the big question dominating french
politics can the far right win the
french presidency well in the last few
moments there's been a jubilant cry of
uh victory here as marine le pen
and president macron are through to the
second round of the french election in
two weeks time marine le pen the leader
of the last one so now that far right
party which has gained a significant
amount of momentum here in france will
be running again against french
president emmanuel macron to take that
seat at the elysee palace now we are
expecting marine le pen to arrive at any
moment and certainly there is already a
real atmosphere of
festivities here this is great news for
marine le pen's supporters she's run a
very smart campaign focusing on
the cost of living which is what is the
most concerning issue for french voters
at the moment and it's really detailed
provider as a candidate she hasn't
talked so much about immigration so much
about islam and she is appealing to a
broader church at this election and
certainly her image has suffered but
critics say she still has the same
far-right values it is a concern to
others here in france that potentially
this is marine le pen's real charge to
take the french presidency is the third
attempt for her at an election and it is
her last chance but the figures are
within the margin of error that we saw
with donald trump's victory in america
and with the brexit campaign
in the uk people here are comparing this
election to those two examples that we
saw unfold in america
and britain and to give you an idea of
the figures tonight president macron
came in at 28 of the vote marine le pen
at
23.3
and certainly
it's in that territory that marine le
pen could potentially
win at the second round now it's not
likely emmanuel emmanuel macron is still
in the lead but what will be very
interesting is where the other votes get
distributed in that second round because
there were 12 candidates in this first
round
and those candidates who haven't got
through it will just be president macron
against marine le pen in round two it's
where people choose to allocate their
votes if they vote
at all now historically
parties would
unite to block a far-right candidate
from getting into office and certainly
it feels much less traditional
in this election i've spoken to a number
of people who are considering voting
marine le pen in round two others who
are saying they're not gonna vote at all
and that could also fuel
a surprise result but certainly
it feels like an unpredictable election
and it certainly feels like marine le
pen is much more palatable now
for french voters it'll it's going to be
a very interesting two weeks and
certainly
an alarm bell for president macron we
can actually show you the figures now
for this exit poll which has just
dropped in the last couple of moments
president macron in at 28.1
and marine le pen the leader of the
rascal national
he is seen as a far left candidate if
you like and er more at 7.2 he's a far
right candidate and marie le pen will
certainly take at least 90 percent of
eric zemor's votes in round two what's
going to be very interesting
is where valerie picked class at five
percent and
a 20
go that's much less predictable
those two candidates
we don't know who they're going to
endorse who they will fight but
certainly at the moment they're the two
to watch in terms of where their voters
decide to lend their votes
at round two in two weeks time
traditionally voters would vote for the
what's viewed to be the safest pair of
hands in round two of the french
presidential election but it feels like
we are in unchartered territory here in
france a number of people are
considering le pen that wouldn't have
previously considered voting for a far
right
party and why is that well president
macron's been in power for five years
now and actually
a number of people still view him as
elite and out of touch and the cost of
living crisis is certainly
the central theme
that marina penn focused on in her
campaign and it really worked for people
that she was leaning left on economics
and the hardship that so many french
people are suffering and it certainly
has given her a sense of appeal here in
france that could just push her over the
line
in round two on the 24th of april as i
say president macron is still ahead
there's no guarantee
she is there's no guarantee of his
victory but he is still ahead it just
does feel like a very unpredictable
election and as history has taught us
with brexit and with donald trump we are
now
in a margin of error wherein those
figures are certainly potentially
vulnerable for disruption
in an unpredictable
round two in two weeks time